رحبت عائلة باتشيكو بأحدث
فتاة لها في أكتوبر ، لكن بعد أيام قليلة أصيبت
الأم كريستينا باتشيكو
بعدوى كادت أن تقضي على حياتها ،
وبدأت الأمور للتو في تدهور أعضائها ،
وانتهى بها الأمر إلى
متلازمة الصدمة السامة ، وهو أمر نادر
جدًا وأنت تعلم أنها مشكلة.  معدل وفيات مرتفع للغاية
يقول جاكوب إن كريستينا
وُضعت على أجهزة دعم الحياة حيث
سارع الأطباء لإنقاذها ومعرفة
ما كان يحدث ، وقد أدى ذلك في النهاية إلى
فقدان كريستينا بعض أطرافها
، واضطرت إلى بتر يديها
وقدميها.
كلتا قدميها وكان الأمر
صعبًا جدًا ولكن مع الحب
والدعم من عائلتها وأصدقائها
قاتلت كريستينا العدوى ،
تقول يعقوب إن كريستينا خضعت لعدة
إجراءات وأن شفائها الذي
سيشمل الأطراف الصناعية سيستغرق شهورًا
ولكن مرونتها وإرادتها في العيش هي
لم يسبق لها مثيل كانت تعرف أنها تريد
العودة إلى المنزل لأطفالها لأنها
تفتقدهم كثيرًا منذ انتشار أخبار معركة كريستينا.
لقد اجتمع الأصدقاء والعائلة في مجتمع أنطون لتقديم المساعدة
بأي شكل من الأشكال للحصول على دعم مذهل من
والدي والديها ، أخي
شقيق زوجتي وزوجته وأخت زوجتي
، يوجد ضوء في
نهاية العنوان  حيث لم يكن هناك
في البداية